Give me this thing here.
Let me try something.
That's good.
Let's give it a shot.
Does this look
fabulous?
Okay, well, we're We aim to please.
Help them up. Yes, yes. Very old man.
[Silence]
And my bad, yesterday
morning, we mentioned the narration
with the author here,
which is one of the narrations regarding
the death of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. And of course, we
mentioned this narration in the vein of
fiqh and trying to learn from it exactly
what of it
applies to us in this particular
context. However,
these narrations
sometimes we learn them,
we read them,
but
because of the nature of
literacy in our time,
there's different types of reading,
right? There's reading that is more like
scanning.
There's reading that is more like
skimming.
There's reading that is studious and and
purely intellectual.
There's reading which is deep, and then
there's reading which is reflective
and a reading of ponderance
and a reading of
cont- contemplation,
right? And all of the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam's narrations deserve
that level of reading.
And the beauty of revelation and why it
is so different than anything else on
Earth.
And this is something that I think we
all feel and it's not just because we're
Muslim or just because we expect
but if you notice that the majority of
or all of the words
of human beings,
no matter how poetic, no matter how
profound, no matter how deep and
insightful, even the words of the
greatest of the scholars of Islam, even
the words of the companions themselves,
they
have a limit to them where you learn
what's in them, you've derived what they
have to give, and you can't really take
them beyond that. And once you reach
that threshold, the novelty starts to
wear off, right? And you want to move on
to something else. Except for the Quran.
The scholars describe it and the
companions describe it before as
that it does not lose its novelty
or its edge, no matter how much you read
it or recite it. As a matter of fact,
it gains in novelty the more you read it
and recite it. We We read a narration
this.
I mean, can we really imagine the weight
of
Here is the messenger of Allah,
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. No prophet,
no messenger will ever come again.
Revelation,
the revelation
between the heavens and the earth is
going to cease with the death of this
man.
And hundreds of thousands of souls at
the same time, simultaneously,
they are
hanging in the balance here. Could you
imagine the weight or responsibility
that the companions felt
that this man is dying and now we have
to somehow carry on this legacy. How can
we possibly carry this on even if
there's a million of us? How? How can we
be certain that we're going to make the
right choices? How can we be certain
we're going to steer this ship
straight and true?
The prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
is in the throes of death.
And you're watching someone that
whatever issue would occur, whatever
problem you would have, you would go to
him. You would ask him. You would
consult him. A living, breathing piece
of revelation, right? And whenever you
feel
whenever the companions felt
beat down or or or low or depressed,
they would sit with him or sometimes
only merely see his face
and that fire would reignite, right?
That fire would
would grow back brighter than ever. Even
in combat, Ali ibn Abi Talib, who's no
slouch in combat. He's known as Layth
al-Hurub wa Faris Quraysh, right? He
says that when we would be in battle
and we could not penetrate the enemies
ranks,
we would open our
ranks for the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam to come forward. And he would
penetrate and we would walk behind him
in the battle,
right? This is what we do today with
tanks.
That's how tanks are used in modern
warfare.
You make the tank go forward, you hide
behind it. This is how infantry works.
And so, we see that this great man,
the greatest human being that's ever
walked the earth,
he's now
lying there. He's he is fainting.
He's waking up and he's saying, "Did the
people pray?"
"No, they're waiting for you."
"Bring me a
[Arabic recitation]
water to bathe and he would bathe
himself and then he would lose
consciousness again and then he would
wake up. He would say, "Did the people
pray?" "No, they're waiting for you. We
just had this conversation."
"Bring me a basin of water." And until
finally he realizes that he cannot get
up, he cannot go pray
and he sends for Abu Bakr al-Siddiq to
lead the salah. What a terrifying time
to be
a terrifying time to be alive, a
terrifying time to be to bear witness,
right? But these are also very important
things for us to learn.
Because in Sunan ibn Majah
the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam,
he essentially tells us, "Don't worry
about me.
Draw strength from my legacy." He says,
He says, "Whoever has a tragedy, a
crisis, a difficulty that he or she is
facing,
remember your great tragedy with me."
Meaning the loss of the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam. What could
be more tragic?
Another
explanation or interpretation of this
narration is
[Silence]
For you to think of that guy.
[Arabic recitation]
whoever is afflicted with a hardship,
then he is to remember my hardship.
Meaning, there's nothing that any of us
is going to
have happen to him. Nothing.
Except that the prophet Sallalahu Alayhi
Wasallam has endured a portion of that
exact
problem.
death of a loved one, death of a
child. Our prophet Sallalahu Alayhi
Wasallam had seven deaths of his
children in his lifetime. Seven. He
buried seven children.
Sallalahu Alayhi Wasallam.
And the eighth
he was told would be the first of his
companions to die after him. Fatima
Radiyallahu Anha, the youngest and his
most beloved. Death of a spouse.
poverty.
he had times when the companions came to
him when they were digging the trench
and they were so hungry
that they showed him that they were
tying stones to their stomach. I don't
think any of us has really ever been
that hungry to where you are so hungry
that your belly expands
with gases
and it it is painful. You have to
physically press on it in order to numb
the pain to an extent. They have
rocks tied to their stomachs and he
lifts his garments and he's got two
rocks tied to his stomach. Sallalahu
Alayhi Wasallam. He didn't tell anybody
about it. He didn't want to show them
because if he showed them, they would
strain themselves to try to find a
solution for that. Right?
exiled. He was exiled from his own land.
Lonely, he was pushed out of his own
homeland for no other reason other than
delivering Allah's message, right? Etc.
etc. Illness,
poverty,
fear. Imagine how afraid he was in
the streets of Mecca. So afraid that
many of the greatest
companions
were afraid to ever recite the Quran
even slightly aloud in their own house
for fear that someone from the mushrikin
would hear them
and
you know, physically either murder
them or hurt them or hurt their family,
etc. This is how much fear they had. As
a matter of fact, one companion, he
said, "Allah sent down the verse,
"Walana baluwannakum bishai'in min
al-khawf."
We are going to test you all with a with
a portion of fear."
And some of the younger companions,
they thought to themselves, you know,
what what could possibly How bad could
it be?
He said, "Before we knew it, we were too
afraid to pray alone behind locked
doors.
That's how scared we were in Mecca,
right? There's nothing you or I are
going to endure that is going to be
equivalent, let alone beyond that. And
that is a huge huge relief for us
because no matter what happens,
no matter where we find ourselves along
the path,
when we look up,
we can find the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam
on the path right right in front of us,
a step ahead. No matter how dark things
get or how lonely or how difficult, we
just have to look up and there he is,
right there in front of us, walking in
front of it. He can't walk for us.
We don't have the son of God that's
going to come and be crucified and take
our sins. No, no, no.
We have to walk the path. No one's going
to walk it for you.
However,
he'll walk right ahead of you, right
there.
Ahead of you.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will take
your hand
and guide you down that path. And so,
this is why the scholars traditionally,
and we'll end with this,
they have traditionally
specified books
just about the prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam's death. An-Nasa'i, for
instance, he wrote a treatise only
compiling narrations regarding his death
and things that happened before, things
that happened after, things that
happened during. Why? Not just so we can
tug on heartstrings and sit around and
cry about it. But this is incredibly
important information for us to have
in order to walk this path cuz this path
is not an easy path. When you're young,
you look at the path, you think, "Oh,
you know, I could do this. What's the
worst that could happen?" Trust me, it's
going to get bad. It's going to get
dark. It's going to get lonely. Your
your faith will be tested and you will
be taken not to the breaking point.
Almost almost going to break you.
You're not going to get broken cuz
Allah's not trying to break you.
But almost and you're going to wish you
were broken.
But he's given you everything that you
need in order to get through that
journey. Everything. And not only that,
but he sent a messenger
to do it all before you do it, so that
you and I both have that
you know, that we we both have that
role model
for us.
And so, it's very important for us to
you know, when we read these in in a
book
setting, we're trying to learn from
them, but it's also very important for
us to
take these things on your own and really
contemplate. When you read about the
Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam being
in Ghar Thawr, running from the
mushrikeen, you need to force yourself
to be there with him.
Look around, feel how he felt when Musa
alayhi salaam was told throw your staff
down. Now, take that monstrous snake,
reach out and grab it. You need to be
there with Musa
when he takes it, right?
If you read the Quran this, nothing
can stop you.
It is only Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
Sky's the limit. As a matter of fact,
what sky? Our Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam didn't even have a sky that
could contain him.
Right? The skies themselves opened up
and he went to just under and before the
throne of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
Allah I mean
Well I know
I can mean
I don't know I mean